put my earpiece in that's one thing we
forgot so I couldn't hear the director
earlier uh it's actually a blessed
relief for both of us good evening and
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored
capitalism is a colorful Riot of banks
Brands and businesses competing for our
cash we give them money they give us the
things we need or desire to make our
lives easier and less miserable that's
the deal but there's a problem I hate
you
I don't simply care if you know it at
some unidentified point in recent
history companies lost interest they
simply selling things and decided it was
their duty to change the way that you
and I think someone somewhere say
corporate board members of the World
Unite and suddenly the people who sell
you fizzy drinks and credit cards were
also telling you that black lives matter
that pride month is more important than
Christmas you're personally to blame the
climate change because of your filthy
carbon footprint and so on and so on
this week Coots Bank my own bank was
exposed for terminating Nigel farage's
account because of his divisive opinions
supposedly and his stance on brexit
here's Dame Alison Rose the CEO of
NatWest which owns Coots
the climate emergency is the biggest
challenge that we're going to face and
as as a bank and the leading Bank in the
UK we have a real role to play clearly
not enough money is going to female
entrepreneurs and there are too many
barriers in their way to helping them
succeed we have targets at our CEO minus
four level right the way through the
organization to encourage all elements
of diversity and inclusivity
well apart from including it seems Nigel
farage so her politics will be clear I
actually have to agree with some of her
causes and Views but also wonder what's
that going to do with my bank I disagree
with Nigel farage's opinions about many
things including brexit but I don't
think he should be denied access to
banking because of them is anybody
well Coots is tonight groveringly
apologize to Nigel Farah I just said
NatWest was offered to find him
alternative arranges but haven't offered
him his account back at Coots the
treasury says it'll toughen up his rules
to make sure this never happens again
but the reputational damage once again
is done it seems orwellian that it ever
happened in the first place and when it
comes to corporate wokery is it just the
tip of the iceberg Ben and Jerry's which
sells ice cream in America blame the
United States for the war in Ukraine
earlier this month it called for
indigenous lands to be returned to
indigenous people before it emerged in
its own HQ was built on land owned by
you guessed it indigenous people what's
the lesson there other than all this
wokery tends to be based on hypocrisy
well maybe it's just stick to selling
ice cream
huh try that old trick
Bud Light I'd be wishing they'd stuck to
selling beer the drink of choice for
millions of sports loving working-class
Americans teamed up with trans
influencer Dylan Mulvaney who was a man
until last year and now spends most of
her time mocking women
um America's favorite Beer Company
decided that that she would be the
perfect person to sell their beer and
absolutely tanked their business because
most of their consumers went what are
you doing
well that debacle has a cost of 27
billion dollars so far the same thing
you might remember happened to Gillette
we suddenly told all its male customers
including myself that we were a bunch of
Harvey weinsteins until we could prove
otherwise they took an 8 billion dollar
write down in value
it's corporate suicide
or maybe it's Maybelline the popular
lipstick merch that last week decided to
tell women they should aspire to be big
bald men with beards when they buy their
lipstick really
why why wouldn't you think that would
work why is no one in your offices like
me going what are you doing you idiots
we'll see how it goes I can tell you how
it's gonna go probably not very well
because most women don't buy lipstick
because a big bold bearded boat tells
them too
last month Adidas chose a biologically
male model complete with visible bulge
to advertise a female swimming costume
again why would you do that
this week we discovered that Disney has
abolished its seven dwarves in a
live-action remake of Snow White and the
Seven Dwarfs the doors have been
replaced by seven magical creatures of
varying shapes sizes ethnicities and
genders actually what that means is one
dwarf actor is still in that Phil about
seven dwarves and the rest are
average height people
so six door factors lost work in a
Hollywood Blockbuster because of wokery
Disney also abolished its famous princes
and princesses because their gender
stereotypes really
can't we just have princes and
princesses anymore
but it does not feature gay kisses and
lots of diversity here's a Disney
executive explaining why
our leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret game like I was just wherever I
could just basically adding queerness to
like if you see anything queer in the
show I'm proud family but like I just
was like no one would stop me and no one
was trying to stop me
why didn't like someone stop you with
you adding acquaintance everywhere I got
no problem with being people being gay
or trans or anything frankly black white
I don't care I treat everyone the same I
expect them to treat me the same
but this stuff is utterly ridiculous why
does Disney which makes fairy tale
cartoons and adventure stories for kids
why doesn't it acquaint this agenda
I don't get it and nor do the consumers
Disney's taken a huge hit as well
recently
I'm not even right-wing
you wouldn't believe it from the way I
get treated on Twitter people call me a
right-wing head banger not right wing at
all is to edit the Daily Mirror
newspaper it's a left-wing newspaper
I think I'm sort of around the center
somewhere really maybe slightly to the
left or over the years are left have got
so nuts I find myself sliding maybe
slightly to the right maybe
because the left has lost its mind this
work stuff is insane and everyone's
getting seconds out of it not least sick
and tired of woke companies telling us
every day that we're evil until we can
prove otherwise I just want to buy an
ice cream I love ice cream without
dismantling the patriarchy whatever that
is